hello everyone welcome to our course on
blockchains and cryptocurrencies my name
is dan bunnet i'm a co-director of the
stanford center for blockchain research
and a professor of computer science here
at stanford i'm co-teaching this course
along with my colleague professor joe
grunfest thank you dan hello everyone my
name is joe grundfest i'm a former
commissioner of the united states
securities exchange commission but i'm
better now thanks for asking i'm also a
professor of law and business here at
stanford this course is a special
collaboration between the computer
science department at stanford and
stanford's law school our goal is to
look at blockchain technology through a
variety of lenses including those of
developers investors regulators and the
media along with your instructors you'll
hear from rising stars in this space
including juan binet founder of filecoin
and ceo protocol labs as well as fred
ursum and matt wong of paradigm fred's a
co-founder of coinbase and matt's a
former partner at sequoia capital
together they offer absolutely
tremendous insight that you simply can't
get anywhere else
by the end of this course you should
understand how blockchain technologies
and cryptocurrencies work what the
immediate and long-term opportunities
are as well as their challenges we want
to arm you with enough information to
decide for yourself how the technology
will evolve and what its impact will be
we hope you enjoy the course and we very
much look forward to speaking to you
soon thank you very much thanks everyone
and we hope you enjoy the course